foreign
tool launched in 2022 changed the way
the world looked at artificial
intelligence an artificial wonder that
can interact with you like a human
solving your queries and helping you
with your daily tasks made it stand out
in the last year looking at the
popularity of chair GPT it's easy to
understand where the AI industry is
heading towards not just chargibility
but there are thousands of AI tools out
there for all your needs whether you are
a working professional a student or a
freelancer from software engineering to
SEO marketing or any of the fields there
are plethora of AI tools curated just
for you to complete your tasks faster
and more efficiently
from writing your code for you to
Preparing technical documentation and
even preparing an entire video for you
to upload on your vlogging Channel AI is
here and you can leverage the benefits
of these AI tools to grow exponential
simply but you name it and AI has it and
in this video we'll cover some of the
amazing AI tools that are present in the
market and just might save the day for
you so stick around until the end
because you will love all the tools but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
these videos and find them interesting
please subscribe to our Channel because
we bring the best videos for you Dean
hit the Bell icon to get notified
whenever we drop a new video also
towards the end if you feel that we
missed on any AI tool and should create
videos around them
mention them in the comment box
we try to make another video around it
so without any further delay let's get
started so let's start this video with
chat GPT chat Deputy is the most popular
tool among all the tools we have for
today
and AI chatbot founded by open AI in
November 2022 what this chatbot can do
is insane it can do Insane number of
things the only thing you should keep in
your mind while using this AI tool is
you should know how to give
prompts so what I mean by prompts is
it's a chatbot right so it knows how to
start a conversation or how to make a
conversation with some person so if I'll
write here hi
so here you can see it gave me an answer
and it says hello how can I assist you
today not just chat GPT but there are
other chatbots as well or you can say
assistance like Google Assistant then we
have CD from Apple and Bixby from
Samsung so all these resistance they are
capable of talking to you right they are
capable of keeping on the conversations
between you and them so not just that
but charge GPT can give you answers to
your problems now if I'll write here
write a program
for
let's say
factorial of a number fine
press enter and here you will see it
will give you the proper code so here
you can see
we have the proper code it can be in
Python you can ask stat Deputy to write
the same in C plus plus then you can
also use Java C sharp or any other
language it's totally up to you which
language you want to use but chatgpt can
give you the answer so the best way to
know this particular chatbot is by
asking it so I'll ask you what is chat
GPT fine we are asking chat GPT what is
shared gbt so here you can see you have
enhanced such as GPT is a language model
developed by open air it belongs to GPD
generative pre-trained Transformer
Series so especially GPT 3.5 so charge
GPT is trained in a particular data set
before 2021 so there are certain
limitations of using chat gbt like which
might overcome in
what we can say gbt4 but which at GPT
there were some limitations so if like
if I'll ask
what
is the date today
fine let's see if chat GPT has the
answer
so here you can see today chatgpt has
the idea of taking the current date fine
what
happened
okay happen
wait let's say Tesla in
March 2023 fine so March 2023 few months
back so here you can see chat Deputy is
an AI language model and its responses
are based on the information available
up till September 2021 so if there is
anything you want to ask at GPT that
happened after 2021 you can't expect a
particular or a correct answer from chat
GPT because it is trained in the data
until September 2021 fine so there are
certain limitations but apart from the
limitations chargpt can do a lot of
things for you like it can help you in
managing your daily life fine so if you
want to write questions like if you have
any sort of essay to write or anything
related to SEO digital marketing any
technology you belong to chat GPT has
the answer for you one or the other way
for example if you want to create a
YouTube video you can ask your GPT to
write a complete script so if I'll write
here write a script
for my YouTube video
where the
title is
uh let's see
best
programming
language
fine press enter
and here you will see it will give you a
complete script so here you can see
opening scene and there's a host smiling
and energetic it will it's giving you
other things as well not just the script
but the role player and how everyone
will do like how to perform that script
that is also chat Deputy is giving you
fine so it is one of the most widely
used AI tool in the current scenario
that's the reason because it has the
answer for everything almost everything
you whether you have any logical
questions programming questions or
anything you are stuck with just go to
chatgpt and ask the question the only
thing you need is the correct way of
writing prompts fine
now here you can see we have the plus
plan for chatgpt as well right now I am
using the current plan which is a free
plan the plus plan you have to give 20 a
month so it's some sort of money you
have to give then you will get the
upgraded version and these are the
benefits for the upgraded plan available
even when demand is high so if you are
using it the free plan it will not be
available if the demand is very high
fine
then the responses paid will change it
will give you faster responses and
Priority Access to new features you'll
get if you upgrade to the current plan
or if you upgrade to the chat GPT plus
plan so chat GPT was a first tool fine
now moving on to the next tool but
before that if you want to accelerate
your career in Ai and machine learning
because Ai and machine learning are the
buzz world today in 2023 AI is the
buzzword specially right so you can
accelerate your career in Ai and machine
learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning when you will gain expertise in
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision and reinforcement
learning you'll also receive a
prestigious certificate fine you'll also
receive exclusive aluminum membership
and hackathons and ask me anything
sessions by IBM because this course is
sponsored by IBM now you will get three
cap students and 25 plus industry
projects using real date assets from
Twitter Uber and more penual green
practical experience master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts in shorts
top-notch education in a post graduate
program in Ein machine learning simply
learned job assist will also help you
get noticed by Leading companies live
sessions on AI trends like chat GPT will
also cover chat GPT in this particular
program then we have generative Ai and
explainable AI as well
so this program covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural networks computer vision Gans and
then we have Keras tensorflow and many
more other skills are covered in this
particular postgraduate program so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below
so moving ahead let's move to the second
tool for the day which is victory.ai so
we'll go to Google and write here
Victory AI and just click on the link
here you can see we can get a free trial
so just click on free trial or login
whatever you want to do just login to
their website and victory.ai it's a
video making tool fine you can use
victory.ai to create videos fine once
you are done with uh
repeat once you are done with login and
all
you will come to this page so here you
can see we have script to video Article
2 video edit videos using text visuals
to audio so it is an AI tool that can
help you in creating videos without even
shooting them fine so here you can see
we have all the
features written over here recommended
for educational videos listical videos
coaching videos step-by-step guides so
here you can see we have what we have to
do is we have to give a script and it
will give us a video it can't be better
right you just have to give the script
so the best ways go to chatgpt ask RGB
to create a script for your video it
will create a script and then take the
script come back to Victory and create a
full-fledged YouTube video for your
YouTube channel or anywhere you want to
post it fine not just that but we have a
dedicated video on how to make videos
using AI tools so if you want to check
out that video you can find the link in
the description box
and definitely check out that video
because there we have created a complete
video from script to the final video
using AI tune only we have not done any
shoot for that video nothing like that
just take the script go to other AI tool
paste it there and you'll get the video
fine or you can just edit your video as
well apart from that we have article to
video as well where we can put the link
of our article and we'll get a video
it's good for blogs press releases and
any HTML article fine
the next one we have is we can edit
videos using text now input videos from
weekend input video from various
resources and you can see most of them
are free and
it also has an upgraded plan right so
here you can see
the upgraded plan and all
so premium 39 dollars per month for
one year fine the Premium plan then we
have the Enterprise plan
for this particular AI tool the
Enterprise plant you can plan you can
customize and you they'll get you all
the customizations done and you are good
with it not just pick 3 but you can also
choose monthly plan so 47 dollars per
month for 60 videos you can get for 47
dollars per month and you'll be able to
create each video of up to 20 minutes
only 60 videos up to 20 minutes means
two videos in a day
it's too much right if you are creating
140 videos you can create of 8 minutes
fine and if you are creating 220 videos
you can create up to 5 minutes fine so
here you can see we have the standard
plan as well which is 23 dollars per
month and apart from that if you don't
want to upgrade just go back to Victory
and you can use the free trial version
just click on proceed and start typing
or paste your script over here then
proceed fine that's how easy it is to
use this AI tool otherwise it takes a
lot of time to create any video or
anything like that
the next tool we have is
durable now durable dot AI is a website
builder for small businesses or
something like that fine all you have to
do is just go to their website and click
on generate your website you can also
sign in so here you can see it's written
the AI website builder that generates an
entire website with images and copy in
seconds
now how easy it is to create a website
using this tool right no need to learn
HTML CSS JavaScript or if you are new to
these languages or if you don't know
them it doesn't matter just go to AI
tools go to this particular AI tool and
create your website within minutes fine
now what we have to do is we have to
enter a business what we can say
business type so if I write here
tracking if I click on next what's the
name of your business
now here you can see we have an image of
the truck of multiple tracks and these
images looks good actually good images
this website is using
so if I write here
Truckers
okay we'll write here trackers and then
we'll build it fine
now it will take some time it will
take the color palettes and it will take
the banners and all these things then
you will get the images testimonials and
other things as well now this website or
this AI tool can create a complete
website for your business if you are
a small business if you own a small
business and you want to start one here
you can see a basic static website this
tool just created in few minutes right
in just few minutes not more than one
two minutes it took and here you can see
we have
different things we have different
images we can regenerate every section
and here you can see we have this
truckers right trackers written away so
mostly when we use when we create any
website what we need is a logo right if
you create any business you should need
you'll need a logo which can make you
stand out of the crowd basically so for
that we have another AI tool fine so
it's easy to create a business like
digital marketing in the area of digital
marketing it's so easy because there are
number of AI tools which can help you
that can help you get your
business to a new level or to a
different level fine so the next one is
brand mark
and here you can see brandmark.ai open
the website and you can create a brand
Mark you can create a logo basically so
if you want to create a logo just right
here
truckers so it was the company name and
slogan it's optional but
will right here let's say if I'm writing
here since
now it will create a logo fine
that describe your brand truck brand
and we'll write here transportation
that's it just click on the next button
you can choose the color style dark soft
pastel vibrant organic so let's try dark
this time
for now we are going to try dark fine
so it's generating a logo
and here you can see it's done
fine so here you can see we have
different logos we have truckers since
and then we have
okay
so just click on new over here just
generate them again
wait for it it will take some time like
creating a logo it takes around five
minutes or something like that so here
you can see the logos are actually good
so here you can see we have multiple
logos right so this logo I like this one
to be really honest so this logo is nice
and
yeah we can copy it or we can just
download it from here but we have to
login First and they should be having a
and a paid program or something like
that so
we are not going to waste our time in
this so if you want to check this tool
out or if you want a proper dedicated
video you can let us know in the comment
section below but right now we are
moving to a next tool find next AI tool
the next AI tool we have is
the quick pen dot AI
so we'll write over here quick pen okay
just a minute
quick pen AI
now it's an AI content writer writing
content is not an easy task right so
we'll just start it for free we'll log
in here
that is it we are in we are in the
website or we can say we are in the AI
tool so it's free up to some extent and
otherwise it's paid mostly so you can
see if you want to write an article you
can use this tool article writer and
it's completely not free of cost
it is actually paid it's in the pro
version the talking points are also in
the pro version then we have article
outlines article rewriter block section
block conclusion blog intros blog ideas
and a lot of things apart from that we
have ai images AI chat speech to text
and text to speech
so we can use all of them right so if I
write here anything like it's speech to
text let's use the text to speech one so
if I am writing here hi there
how are you
now here you can see we can't use the
characters because we don't have any
characters so we can't use this feature
right now we can use certain templates
because we have
25 words limit as a free trial so you
can use for 2500 words only fine after
that you have to buy the Premium plan
for that you have to upgrade the plan
and
you can see we have the membership free
plan one time we can change the plan and
it's the cost of the plan monthly you
will have to pay 39 per month basic you
have to pay 19 per month
and if you want to go for yearly plan
you have to pay 429 yearly 209 yearly
for basic block
and for Lifetime
okay the lifetime plan looks a good deal
fifteen hundred dollars for the whole
lifetime
now it's fine right so for the free plan
these are not accessible new features
you can't access prior email support you
can't access prior all the tools you
don't have access to all the tools image
generation is not there text to speech
is not there
and here you can see you will get 2500
words per month
here you will get 25 000 per month and
unlimited words per month in the Pro
Plan fine same rules for the monthly
plan as well the basic plan and the
Pro Plan so there are three different
plans so you can use this particular AI
tool to create content for you now SEO
and all SEO optimized content also this
AI tool can create if you will go to
templates and it will it can create blog
ideas blog intros titles
and they are like catchy block titles
with this tool you can create catchy
block title and the next day I tool we
are going to discuss is the mini gpt4 so
if you'll type here Mini gpt4
you'll come to this website and then
here is the mini GPT Force
but we can say abstract and all the
details about this particular
tool fine so here you can see this is
the
tool so here you can see the tool you
can take some images and this tool takes
a lot of time to just
make something out of something really
useful out of an image fine so if we'll
go a space
so here you can see
here we are we can drag an image over
here or
but it takes some time so like right if
I click here click on upload and if I go
to pictures
if I have any images I'll see
so we have some images here let's use
this one
and upload and start it now it will take
some time so here you can see it's going
to take 21 seconds just to upload this
image
the good part is you get to know about
the time and it's just a
what we can say tool right AI tool and
it will create something useful out of
your image it will gather data from your
image and if you are giving it an image
of a leaf or leaf then it will tell you
which kind of leaf it is and how which
three it belongs to and all that so here
you can see
we can ask questions now what is this
fine if I write here what is this now
here you can see it is generating
response it will take some time
and mini gpt4 usually takes a lot of
time in comparison to GPT 3 or GPT 4. so
here you can see this is a cartoon image
of a baby grooter with the big eyes and
a cute expression the image is not very
detailed but it is still cute and fun to
look at the baby router is willing
wearing a small outfit with a white
undershirt and here you can see it's
giving complete details about the image
right and brown overalls the overall
design is simple and cute making it
great addition to any project or design
can you tell me
from which
movie this
character is I guess you guys all guys
know which movie this character belongs
to and if you know then do let us know
in the comment section below we'll see
if you really know who is he right so
you you can see here it's taking 32
seconds just to generate the response
until then what we are going to do is we
are going to move to our next tool we
are not going to waste any time the next
tool in our list is
Jasper Jasper AI Jasper I guess a lot of
you guys already knows about Jasper what
Jasper is and how Jasper works
so we'll write here try just for free
okay we have to login
so here you can see we are in the
upgrade upgrade plan option here we have
39 per month for create a 99 per month
for teams built-in value both of them
and then we have business plan which you
can customize fine
let's choose any free trial I don't
think jasper.a will allow you to do all
this without
using the
what we can say free details so until
then I'll explain you what Jasper AI
actually is but before that let's check
the answer from mini gpt4 here you can
see this character is from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this character is
known as Groot and this GPT actually
knows who he is and he's a member of the
Guardians of the Galaxy Groot is a small
plant like creature who is the last of
his kind he is known for his loyalty and
bravery and he's a beloved member of the
Guardians team root has appeared in
several movies and TV shows in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe including
Guardian of the Galaxy Avengers Infinity
war and Avengers end game
so you can see how good this AIA is
right so we can use this AI to get some
sort of information out of any image
right chat Deputy does not provide us
with this feature charity does not give
us any sort of image fine so what is
Jasper jasper.a is an AI writing tool
designed to generate marketing copies
such as blog posts product descriptions
company bios ad copy and social media
caption the tool offers hundreds of
templates to choose from responding to
many scenarios like if you want to write
a long term full it takes the stress of
a blank page right out of the writing
currently jasper.ai is best for
marketers offering advantages to
companies of any size
the features include it can create text
and image from AI integration with
grammarly and other Chrome extensions
which is quite normal these days you can
also reverse from your history auto save
document sharing multi-user login
plagiarism Checker and brand voice
customization so if you are starting
your brand then you can definitely check
out this tool but it's not free
so
you have to keep this thing in mind you
have to pay some sort of amount apart
from this tool we have the
other tools right we have uh which one
we had we just discussed it
we discussed quickpen.ai it can do the
same task although it was also not free
but let's move on to our next
AI tool which is a lot of you guys
already know about this tool it is
flexity
AI now perplexity can also get you
answers
so what complexity can do is it will get
you answers with suitable reasons it
will justify its answer
so what I will write is what is
the most recent
news about
Tesla fine if I write a Tesla here you
can see it's generating answers
so here you can see the most in the
independent provides the latest breaking
news comment and features about Tesla
but there is no specific news mentioned
in the search result
so Tesla RT provides news and insight on
Teslas model 3 Model X model S the
gigafactory Tesla energy and more so
here you can see we have one two return
over here if you click on this one two
it will take you to the website from
where it took the information so this is
the website Tesla RT and similarly it
can replace Google's Chrome browser
because why because Google gathers all
the data and gives it to you right it's
up to you which data you want to access
and what you don't want to accept but
here if you want to search something it
it's more of a search engine kind of
thing and you will get the exact news
with a proper resource mentioned right
after the news fine here you can see not
just news but anything you are searching
you will get a proper justification why
this thing is here why this sort of
statement or why this sort of
information is present over here
publicity gives you the information the
complete information so perplexity is
another important AI tool which is going
to
become popular if not tomorrow then
maybe in some time it will be popular
the next AI tool we are going to discuss
is
Lexica fine
Lexica AI we have
now let's open it it's a fun tool to use
it's an image generation tool
now you can change the number of columns
one two three four five six seven eight
here the AI is quite easy to what we can
say use and it's quite simple but yet
you can see look at the images these all
are AI generated images and they look
just on the next level now what you have
to do is you have to continue or you
have to log in here
so here you can see
we have to describe the image if I'll
write here
an astronaut
swimming
in the ocean it's just a random scenario
we'll get an AI generated image of the
scene so here you can see it's
generating the image so all these tools
are quite useful when it comes to air
because every tool has its own use own
benefits own advantages own
disadvantages but at the end all of
these tools are fun to use right not
just fun to use but they are actually
useful so here you can see these are the
AI generated images wow here you can see
an astronaut swimming in the ocean here
because we have four Images these AI
generated images they are on the next
level you can see right there are a
number of such AI tools present in the
market but we chose Lexica because it's
free to use and it's
look at the images you can you can get
an idea about how these images are and
how this AI tool works right you can
also change the resolution of these
images
let's change it to 1088 by 896.
and you can see it's written over here
we are experiencing heavy traffic expect
slower generation I times and so it will
take some time
until then let me introduce to you the
last tool for the day which is chat
Sonic
now we'll go to the website and here you
can see it's clearly lit written chat
gbt alternative built with superpowers
chatsonic now gbt4 powered
it's clear right the website itself says
chat GPT
it's child gbt but it's an alternative
to charge GPT with some superpowers and
it is free to use a revolutionary AI
like chat GPT chat Sonic
the conversational AI chatbot addresses
the limitations of chat GPT turning out
to be the best free chat GPT alternative
let's start chatting with them until
then here you can see we have images of
this resolution now Dimensions now and
look at the images they are all on the
next level
astronauts swimming in the ocean I like
Alexa very much
so here you can see we have the features
of chatsonic so here you can see it's
integrated Google search for the latest
information AI image generation and we
can also get here the disadvantage of
shared GPT
then voice command so you don't need to
type we can also use voice commands then
we have past question it remembers past
questions or comment in our conversation
and can easily answer follow-up
questions text to speech like Siri or
Google Assistant edit copy download and
share a specific response or even your
entire conversation with your friends
colleagues family and followers talk to
chatsonic as a specific personality like
teacher fitness trainer extractor
so these are the features that makes
jetsonic a better place than chat GPT so
here you can see it's not completely
free to use but you have a limit of 10
000 words if you will click here you can
see we have
Superior GPT 4 and then premium gbt 3.5
2 54.25 million Generations up till now
wow chat Sonic is also on a different
level
right oh
Crypt YouTube video script
okay we'll write Here YouTube video
script on
best
programming
language click enter here you can see
jetsonic is
searching online and it's searching
online means two times the words will be
charged
let's see how many words we are going to
get or how many how much how long we
have to wait and here you can see we
have the script hello and welcome to
this video on best programming language
to learn in 2023 now it's not working on
the data up till or until 2021 here you
can see it's written here clearly 2023
and it can work like that fine and we'll
check if it if this is also based on
previous data and or something like that
what is chat Sonic what is chat Sonic
so here you can see it's again searching
online and here you can see python was
declared as the best programming
language by Chet Sonic here it has a
very simple and easy to learn syntax
which is yes python is one of the
easiest to learn languages
is an AI power chat platform developed
by the technology company right Sonic
that uses a sophisticated machine
learning model based on neural networks
to generate the content and simplify
communication it can create various
types of content such as text images and
AI generated art
so let's just
okay General AI we can change the
personality as well here fine
so you can see we have the prompts
Library also here you can select or edit
prompts from here there are here are a
number of prompts so just copy this one
from here
okay
primary keyword so we have to give a
primary keyword best
programming language
okay other keywords
python
let's see if it works or not
so here you can see this a user
interface for chatsonic is a little more
colorful when compared to chat GPT field
go to chat GPT here you can see it's
quite simple that's why it looks better
now again it depends on the choice from
person to person I like simple things
that's why for me chat GPT the UI of
chat DBT was better chat Sonic also has
some sort of colors which are good and
here you can see a few meta title it
will give you the meta title choosing
the best programming language a
comprehensive guide then it has
description introduction but is a
programming language criteria for
choosing best programming language so
that's all for chat Sonic as well now
you decide which of these tools you guys
like the most do let us know in the
comment section below and if you feel
that we should cover some other tools as
well as we mentioned earlier as well
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below we'll try
to create another video on those tools
as well so that's all for this video
guys we'll see you next time
and if you have any questions or queries
related to any of the tools or topics we
have covered in this particular video
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below and a team
of experts will definitely answer them
for you thank you so much for being here
guys we'll see you next time until then
keep learning and stay tuned to Simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here